what up everybody welcome to another
episode of flagrant sue I got some news
very important before we start the show
got a great episode today but I know a
lot of you guys have been asking me how
you can get tickets to the special all
four shows sold out well we spoke to the
production company we asked them to move
around some gear and possibly create
some more space for people and they
accommodated so we've added more seats
to every single show they will go up
today as you're listening to this right
now I think at 9 a.m. they go on sale
the Andrew Schultz calm go get them as
soon as you can I think there might be
like 80 seats a show or something like
that
go get them ASAP spread the word tell
your friends tell the world thank y'all
so much for selling out these shows man
we're doing everything they can and make
sure every single one of you guys is
able to get there so go do that and
spread the word thank you so much now
let's start this show
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of flagrant to schulte here
Akash in a build and Alex media we have
ed in theatre Turkey and we have some
hyenas with us fellas you know we have
the history hyenas Yanis Pappas Chris
Edie in the building
Chrissy fresh off of a podcast what do
we call it when we go to the west coast
and just kind of indulge in the podcast
rock it was on a podcast blitzkrieg you
want a podcast my feet when Chris goes
west coast to do two podcasts is you
know what a Tasmanian devil
yeah that's what my Instagram feed it's
just like you on Theo like I got warts
it was just gotten people Santa it was
just every [ __ ] wild story of your
childhood yeah well your father was
clearly not around yeah that wall I just
let those when I go out there I just let
stories rip reality of suggestions
before and there's people that are like
hey that story had a different ending
last time and I'm like well it's what it
is it's a different [ __ ] reality guy
that was 2019 now it's 2020 when I go
into those la pau championship round
like I literally go in there and I take
deep breaths like I like literally like
I was playing ball like Brian when I
went there Bryan Callen and Brendon
Walken stars like um just go to the
bathroom I said STP which I did when I
did ten deep breath right him suggests
and then I just go ready to go and
whenever it is sometimes I'm a hyper gay
sometimes I'm hyper straight
I just don't know when I am [ __ ]
swinging for those fences still tickets
out here yeah crazy you are I think the
best podcast guess right now I
appreciate I really think it yeah I was
I was who was I talking about was it do
you I was talking who maybe was mark and
Alex or some like that but it was just
like you swing for the [ __ ] fences
there is it's no-holds-barred approach
now I don't care what anybody thinks
about you I couldn't give a [ __ ] at all
I mean that's why even with your pal
your podcast is in the same things like
you come in here and you better have
[ __ ] to say like I just went oh there we
go
yeah just went Chris watch the death
before yeah
yeah I'm just watching this guide I'll
be about thirty this story gonna end the
same doesn't get any more 2020 then when
you're visiting someone who's on their
deathbed and then you know I gotta go I
got to do a pod yeah I was and I was
with I was with Kunal Aurora was also in
there I was like I gotta go do a podcast
with the better version of you Kunal 2.0
and I said and but yeah it was one of
those things where it's like you know
every time he would stop talking or he
would like go to like you know like
literally like spit up blood I would
just check my phone yeah and it's just
you know I'm sorry to do that but it's
just a symptom of 2020 reality I mean I
love that guy you know I was thinking
tickets to sell we started so it's a
can't you got a nice table behind buying
a ticket yeah I mean his if you're a
bush around the bush and a kid goes down
I mean you assess whether he could be
saved and if not you gotta you gotta
make it all the way people go through
the podcast yes so let's let how you got
a time we got to be here yeah Schultz
studios take your socks and shoes off
let's get Arjun young - yeah it's an
Asian I can't believe you don't have
guests flips yet they're coming we have
the fashion flops coming and it's gonna
be you guys will be the first person
nice yeah where's people to get a pair
as long as I don't have your face on it
like Mao I'll be happy I'll be wild it's
just his face dog women which mal man he
put his face on it he probably did I
imagine because it was the most
relatable face I just I just feel like
if you think maybe ya me fix it other
Asians put it on like I could see myself
in this I think he put it on his face he
was like them yeah he probably just
studied you know it's mal but it could
be any older Asian guy am I on my flips
yeah I'm [ __ ] it was hard enough to
tell Asians apart before it now with the
coronavirus mass how do you even know
yeah you you can't tell me you notice
who your mother or father is if it's
just the eyes in a mask now you can't
there's no way you got to give me a
little bit of lip or the bottom of their
nose that's only think it's a little
different about them sometimes Asians
got different lips but the [ __ ] top
of the heads is all the same yeah so if
you want to commit a crime in your Asian
right now yeah I would say now's the
time there's no way the FBI can find you
if they got those masks absolutely
they're wearing those mess for long time
maybe one of those mess before corner so
it's like what did they know you know
I'm saying like anyway knows math for a
long time or does it work clearly it
doesn't work yeah that's a good point
the corona mask I don't think it works
are you [ __ ] kidding me the masks are
made in China they're [ __ ] dip in the
mask in corona just spread it around it
was made in a lab dude so here for me in
bats those [ __ ] people eat things way
more to see done to the bags Bryce
you're a [ __ ] news are you read we're
on the real [ __ ] calm
yo actually I was thinking about that
because the disease only kills old
people as of now right right and who has
the oldest people Chinese yeah and these
people will not die right may have a
problem they got to have any old-school
problem maybe they're trying to get rid
of people and with it I personally think
that they because it under a microscope
it looks the same as HIV that's what
they say so therefore it had to have
been made right that's a that's
something uh the Nature doesn't do that
man doesn't it man see something that
kills and then so I'm not saying that
they actually meant to do that
but they somehow made that in a lab and
then it got out in wuhan Klein I don't
know how it got out but it got out yeah
and and now it's causing problems but I
can't [ __ ] take seriously you talk in
science with Where's Waldo socks lemon
pants on just yeah just I can't look I
got Lulu so it can we put something over
his socks like a [ __ ] did anyone have
a washcloth we can drape over him yeah
cuz I can't concentrate looking at his
[ __ ] Where's Waldo son I got Lulu's
on and did you say son cuz you here at
Schultz did you told me to pull up I'm
out of here
yeah listen Mike Schultz can I know you
guys pull up yes I'm sorry I didn't
phrase the right choice when you call me
for the next week I'm just gonna say
talk to me yeah
would talk to me or 191 the main one
though is there's a world where yeah
we've got them all yeah got insecure
about that cuz someone told me that I
say that um II saw it was probably you
made my girl said it but basically a lot
of everybody had an inside joke
everybody was having inside jokes I've
been trying to like rephrase that
there's a world where it's good man
we're not talking about the world
yah TP bro so tell us there's something
that's very important if any of you guys
follow Yanis on on twitter man we got to
support his because you know he's been
going was in a blackout what I say I
don't know but it was something super
heavy what was it I don't know
I personally loved it yeah I love the
heavy stuff yeah from you yeah yeah as
part of who I am yeah but yeah coming
from the woods who were looking at
horses this morning yeah what did I say
when I came in here and you came in
heavy right what I said Chris easily
came from a dead body
yeah I tell you right now this is what I
deal with on an everyday I find the
character called yani long days and it's
just you know you got to deal with stuff
like this every once in a while you know
listen this is three o'clock in the
morning actors stop boasting about your
virtue you're getting so over being rich
and famous for a job a child can can do
for a job
a child man often does he always has
spelling mistakes yes Marshall middles
know to lay low during after a robbery
not bring attention to themselves shut
the [ __ ] up like Keanu yeah we'll start
to figure out the hustle Sondra I gotta
bring back the character
the weights on it yo and he says or else
your jobs will go to criminals that make
license plates and drugs like in
Shakespeare's day yeah is that right
criminals used to be the ones at the
drops they were giving the drunks like
job yeah they'd throw like hey you wanna
make a couple pence they'd star in his
Shakespeare Shakespeare was famous and
nobody knew who the actors were the
tweet is basically saying like we know
what it's basically saying it's the four
minutes to read the point of Twitter is
to basically say in the first place you
know what's the best part about wrong
one of the good parts about Roman
culture that we figured out while we
write you discovered once so they used
to if you were a criminal right and back
you committed a crime you were [ __ ] by
jury or peers whatever they would put
you you would get to act in a play like
a stage play that the Emperor would go
to and if there was a scene where you
got killed in the show they'd kill you
for real that's how you died that was
your death since you would get killed on
stage in front of everybody for the art
[ __ ] yeah it's kind of cool just get
beheaded you'll get eaten by line
I mean we're heading there that's all
snacks that's a real why would you agree
to do it well you have no choice you're
in jail that's what you have to just
stay in jail you kill me in jail you're
not gonna kill me in front of the whole
city my thinking they would just do it
because they had respect I don't know
they would I don't know it's just a
thing that we read that we discovered
one guy did it hey enough for me for my
stories for Chrissy's world yeah he
tells a story you just it could be could
not you just got it whatever reality is
a suggestion suggests I never know okay
have you guys been to Portland yeah
again yeah okay so we're in Portland
doing shows this past weekend and I have
never experienced ruder people mmm in my
entire life hmm I was absolutely baffled
we went to this place called Pine Street
biscuits pine state biscuits out lesbos
oh they're all lesbos because there's
one that's all [ __ ] les they're all I
suppose yeah and I and we go in there
and there wasn't really a seating area
there was like a kind of like some
barstools or some [ __ ] but I want to
like sit down I want to like that like
service you know it's voodoo doughnuts I
go up to the girl I go who's at the
counter and I go hey just like curiosity
can you recommend like a diner or
something around here we just want to
have like some like you know
table service I'm like that and she goes
she was uh do you smartphone I go yeah
she was you might want to try typing
that in it [ __ ] dude
I wanted to grab her by the back of her
skull and just slam her forehead with a
curve ball headed into the [ __ ]
counter dude I could not it was so much
you know like as a comic you expect
yourself to have a witty retort yeah it
was a shower gas I was flattered I would
I say yeah
I go did that just happen like I started
laughing like halfway into her statement
cuz I know where it was going I was like
I can't believe she say dude [ __ ] when
she said do you have a smartphone I
thought there was an app for good places
to eat in Portland that she was gonna
recommend right I was I was like yeah I
do like I booked the bait yeah
an idiot I took this Bay yeah I do and
then just type that into your smartphone
and then [ __ ] walked away do you
think she recognized the walkaway
bothers me cuz that she does cinnamon
yeah at least I can have a chance at a
really witty retort if you sit in it I
had once how you [ __ ] you I had [ __ ]
nut bit they're all like that dude it
was unbelievable cuz you didn't bring
your sword
you didn't expect you didn't expect for
a duel to happen I did it you were just
asking for a replace it started on the
way I'm on the flight over there the the
flight attendant goes we have two
options we have oatmeal or a creo omelet
I go what's in the Creole omelet she
goes eggs is there something about my
face where people think they could be
rude to me I'm like there's a lot about
your face I realized while I'm out there
is that Portland is white people without
God without religion white dangerous
white person that's a manger is white
person because gogo they use need
something to check you we need a check
yes [ __ ] balance food and when I mean
religion about the Crusades but they had
a God and they did some come on 400
years ago
that's what everybody a couple but they
did way more good than bad they molested
a few kids they fed like the whole world
couple think about strode yeah trade
those kids for the millions of people
they know it's already Fillion yeah that
takes Chris I'm a Catholic list and I've
taken a few off the [ __ ] it knows you
know that it's chairing gal mind it
yes I guess what fuels charity its what
fuel sharing is boys yeah ask Epstein
yeah it is yeah
that's science it's versus so Catherine
he got molested my friends my friends
yes tattoos all over my back end I still
all still go to church or support it
yeah there we go sin doctrine did you I
respect like Catholics the way they can
sort of create a safe place for
themselves right like they can push down
the truth and live in a place yeah well
why do they have to be perfect that's
why I understand like why does every
single aren't people don't people sin
isn't it baked into religion to people
[ __ ] up it doesn't have to be the
Catholicism it's wrong and has to be the
people that touch the kids that are
wrong yeah but that's the whole method
that the priests use to win your
confidence like you said no they're
molesters that go what should I do
so I can take advantage of kids Oh be a
priest that works exactly right it's
like a cover for a pedophile yes I think
the whole thing is that can you do
elaborate the whole thing I think the
whole thing is an elaborate operation oh
yeah I mean looking about cyl basketball
I never got molested see why what do you
mean track kids you [ __ ] you do you
do basketball leagues you do schools
every the kids because the kids are the
money who's your [ __ ] your dad nobody
whose authority can you never question
whose authority would a family ever
question
someone you call father who talks to
Jesus and bring
leave your son with me we're gonna put
him in school yeah we're gonna teach him
there's gonna be who's gonna be with me
he's under my god into my village right
how do you think they were able to get
away with it for so long it only came to
light you know this is what years of any
podcast I mean but it's like that's what
they've been doing playing molestation
to agree
I woke up at 4 o'clock in the morning I
was gonna have a [ __ ] great day and
he had a tweet that said the wheels of
history are greased with blood and I was
like what they are you say that [ __ ]
like no one knows it was telling you the
purpose of the Catholic Church is to
molest kids
Yanis it's a cover for buildings yeah
gargoyles do gargoyles
yeah well what about the buildings what
about the churches don't care about art
kids don't care about marble cuz don't
care about sculpture that is in their
dark souls the architecture is a
manifestation of the Dark Lord's and now
it's like what you're doing the thing
that you're saying they're doing you're
creating this place just for them
you got scripture anybody and I'll
[ __ ] be a hundred percent transparent
on the right now yeah oh I I had mostly
great great great experiences being an
altar boy playing see whale going the
church growing up in a Catholic family
there was a couple of instances where I
would I told you I would go ask father
Bill father bill asked me to get his
cloak from the upstairs part of the
church and I blacked out yeah so that I
don't know necessarily what happened but
it was a blackout and but I'm telling
you even me going through that and I did
that's even charitable that they make
you black out and forget about it like
most molesters you got to carry that
[ __ ] for the rise your life don't look
you don't remember anything I don't
remember it was a blackout and but I do
not I won't have my daughter in Catholic
stuff and my body touches the heroes
yeah girls my daughter's a lesbian
though that's another thing though wise
yeah I don't know she just acts a little
gay but it's fine she's just I don't
know she's just scissors the other kids
[Laughter]
maybe she like had one of your podcasts
on in the background and she was like
men are discussed manner there's no
wonder she was she's now she was gay I
don't care she's cute homosexual
your sexual she's gonna be sexual I
don't care if my child is gay at all and
I actually don't care if they're trans
as long as she votes to the right to the
right I mean what we she already knows
for every kid sure he knows are gonna be
Puerto Rican on college applications
white on job
yeah one more fifty-fifty yeah a hundred
percent that's not gonna change I know
Elizabeth warning
yeah it's not gonna change that's by the
way we should've did when that Portland
lady
said use your smartphone should he just
said Trump 2020 you should say that
right yeah you're right she would have
[ __ ] involved I didn't have [ __ ] you
got for me you got your smart phone hag
four more years
those your America great sucks what is
that what they aren't these socks yeah
yeah these are this is laundry day socks
I don't know why I put these puppies on
there's this thing that happens to us
and I don't know what the [ __ ] it is but
we need some sort of like purpose
because otherwise you just go like this
you go well why should I be nice to this
person if life is pointless yeah you
need some sort of driving force at least
in Seattle where they're like real
hippies you have to be nice as part of
that hippie culture you have to treat
someone with decency right and they buy
into it Portland they're not hippies
just fearless hair people who are
religious fear God not have no God
nothing except black people and that's
where al comes in handy you've got to
ask all the questions in Portland yo
that's something dick if you tell them
but they were super nice to al super
enough super nice to him they feel bad
we were having this other conversation
too while we're out there right because
I'm really trying to understand the [ __ ]
Portland was and you know how like
there's this like alright bastion of
like alright nests in like because its
surround Oregon yeah that it's not in
Portland but it's like right in Oregon
is very red very red yeah good and all
that KKK all that kind of [ __ ] and I can
objectively say this as a white guy
objectively say us those are not the
best whites they make better audience
members than people in Portland though I
will say they'll laugh more at your joke
and they're not good people I tell you
something you'll crush in front of that
can I tell you something audiences were
amazing in Portland amazing and this is
always how it is the more annoying a
city the better the people you are the
Tharsis for the day [ __ ] yes cuz nobody
is saying it and then we go there we
said they're like thank you
yeah somebody [ __ ] understand so they
were incredible this is nope there's
nothing about the people that came out
but there's something about the people
there right they're like these white
people like are we're white supremacist
or some [ __ ] like that they're like
140-pound there's there's way better
whites
there in the world we know this for sure
peeps are in [ __ ] Netherlands six six
[ __ ] white B he best whites yeah the
best whites probably right I would say
Norwegians no no no no not sweet sweet
sir weak their little beta but
Norwegians or if you have you seen a
[ __ ] Dutch uh speedskater body good
bodies have you seen that body
no but I'm serious yeah please check it
out where do you check out speed skating
Norwegians Winter Olympics not no no no
we oh sorry Dutch shush go dutch I don't
get specifically [ __ ] Scandinavians
like I mean not today that's a Norway
Scandinavia Germans are still the best
white [ __ ] muscle ass male go to male
I want to see a hot a nice just Dutch
[ __ ] that is a nice pot so so we're
figuring this out right okay okay we're
in Portland and we're having this
discussion
I'm like why the [ __ ] right you see all
the like the most racist whites Trey the
most racist whites are not white
supremacists we're the most progressive
whites are actually white supremacist of
course I'll make this point I got ya so
because thing about the most racist
whites are don't feel like they're
supreme they're fearful the mixing to
steal our jobs the black guys are gonna
[ __ ] our women or take all our you know
basketball [ __ ] positions etc like
that they're fearful of minorities
they're afraid because they don't
believe they're supreme those Norwegians
they're like yeah welcome come to our
country black people argue learn husky
come a Muslims come to our country we
don't [ __ ] care we don't think you're
a threat cuz the progressive whites
really believe they're better and they
don't why progressive American whites
not only do they not see you as a threat
they pity they pity that's why I hate
him don't pity me [ __ ] you I [ __ ] you
because you want to smoke you want to
toe I'm better
I haven't proved it to you and if you're
giving me the way and [ __ ] you and
that's [ __ ] so on some level when
you look at like those racist southern
hillbilly whites you actually have to
look at them like no they actually see
if you're a non-white person you got to
would actually see me is better yeah
it's a compliment yeah yeah you don't
want to compete with you yeah you're bad
form
yeah but the people who it's like if I'm
playing basketball with somebody and I'm
not good but I'm much better than I look
like I would be if you just letting you
like if you're not playing actual
defense I'm gonna put the [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] you this image of this
like bunch of like white races chanted
up chasing a black guy in the black guy
going like I'm so flattered Arianna is
now as a black dude you get to prove how
fast you are to catch me up yeah I think
we just have white people just they've
recently found out that white people are
the only people on the planet that have
like 2 to 5 percent in the end earth all
DNA this is just a fact
it's a it's maybe that's maybe we're
just evil maybe we just have a vitamin D
deficient in III oh you weren't here for
this you weren't here for this Chrissy
but we're having this conversation
before the three of us and we're talking
about like why America like why we're
such savages here right and it's not
just white so it's just we're all
[ __ ] savages here in America and we
chalked it up to like people that wanted
opportunity or whatever it is right but
it's not that we're a country of [ __ ]
sociopaths we're a country of people my
mother included left her entire family
the only people that loved her in
Scotland to never see again
unless she flew him in she was totally
fine not seeing her mom ever again
that's a sociopathic sure mentality we
have an entire country of drugs people
and that's why socialism or communism
doesn't make sense because when
Europeans go well don't you want to take
care of them
and it's like I don't even want to take
care of my mom yeah I don't care about
them I'd care about nobody yes that's
that's why all the psychosis and the
crazy [ __ ] is a four year well it's here
but it's in Los Angeles specifically
because then even a smaller microcosm is
this craziest one of those Americans
yeah go to Los Angeles and then they
create and then they run the media so
now you think oh that there's all these
problems when it's like all those people
want us to [ __ ] and [ __ ] your children
and suck your blood Jana said the same
thing I'd be careful cuz use your alert
with the line there run it and run the
run in the media and just coming from
that face in Ridgewood you just gone
like alright just lets you run a rope
like this wind gusts coming it went like
this but you stay down
yeah no I'm doing better because my
friend is dying you know kids we were
talking about this because this German
okay with this girl being gay reality
from a German neighborhood yeah he's
mostly German and Ridgewood is a
traditionally mostly German neighborhood
you believe this [ __ ]
I know it for a fact the Italian sitcom
fails and he's got a German wild guy the
crazy [ __ ] this guy's genius he's a
[ __ ] don't believe it he's not a real
person he's over you just keep it moving
he's here for the pleasure of everybody
whatever you need he will provide you
with everyone and good whatever you need
yeah I don't care when I go home I
[ __ ] unzip my skin it's why did I
just step out into something you've
never seen but here's the funny thing
about Germans here's a funny thing about
Germans
[Laughter]
let's take a break for a second and let
y'all know about some shows that we got
coming up you know obviously those
tickets are available for the special we
just added those seats are made those
seats available so make sure you go get
those Neandertals calm orlando we'll see
you this weekend shows sold out thank
y'all so much
after that Richmond Virginia those
tickets are sold out but you can come to
Virginia Beach I think we still got a
few tickets left in the Virginia Beach
show Charlotte North Carolina which will
be that following Sunday that we still
have a few tickets left for that go get
those then New Jersey stress factory
sold-out Minneapolis we had a second
show some tickets available for that
Milwaukie
we got tickets available for that show
as well and so do we have tickets
available for Tucson and Tucson will be
the last show that I do before the
special the English shows calm for all
these spread the word spread the
flagrancy come on out and enjoy your
damn cells are cost what you got man
March 12th through 14th that's this week
I'm going to be in Montreal Thursday
Friday Saturday come through let's pack
that [ __ ] out I want to destroy all the
Canadian markets I know this mad Indians
there in Montreal come through let's do
it the day before that I'm doing a
college gig in Canton New York at st.
Lawrence University every time I do a
college gig there's always some [ __ ]
that hit me up that's like hey I live
there if I'd have known how to come
message me if you hear this I'll get you
in we'll figure it out don't worry about
it
also March 27th I'm gonna be in the den
theater in Chicago who must come through
a cell that [ __ ] out and May 7th
Vancouver I'm coming every Punjab being
Surrey better be in that [ __ ] let's go
Ellen it out theaters let's sell this
theater out yo guys very important if
you're selling anything online okay
an online store you're getting rid of
sneakers you're getting rid of clothing
you're doing anything with regularity
while you're selling online and a lot of
people are using eBay using Craigslist
using all these other apps whatever if
you need to organize your shipping you
have to use ship station comm it's very
simple okay
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage ship your
orders just a few clicks and you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
and getting your product out fast to
keep your customers happy ship station
makes it easy okay
turn this side hustle into a business
okay you have to manage the content you
have I don't care if that content is a
pair of clothing out care if it's
sunglasses you make stocks you make
whatever you're selling manage it
efficient sufficiently know where it's
going know when it gets there and you
can do all this with shipstation
simple as that helps you get orders out
quickly you save money on shipping costs
and keep your customers happy
now what remember what you're selling
doesn't matter Amazon Etsy your own
website shipstation brings all your
orders into one simple interface making
them truly easy to manage from any
device even your cell phone ship station
works with all the major character
carriers USPS FedEx UPS even Amazon
Fulfillment so you can compare and
choose the best shipping solution for
you and your customer they even offer
big discounts on shipping costs now any
business can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved for
large fortune 500 companies take that in
these fortune 500 companies that are
sending out tons of merchandise they get
discounted rates on postage with
shipstation you get that you're always
gonna know that you're gonna get the
best deal shipstation is the number one
choice for online sellers you'll ship
more in less time with the best rates
available need i say more
simply if this applies to you use it
save some money that's all we're trying
to do is help you save a little bit of
money and right now you can try
shipstation for free that's right that
saves you even more money when you get
to try something for free for 60 days
when you use it offer code flagrant okay
think
about that shipstation comm use the
offer code flagrant you will try it for
free for 60 days if it works you keep
using if it doesn't you doesn't there so
confidence gonna work that you're gonna
save money that you that they're willing
to give it to you for two months simple
as that if this can help or affect your
life in any way
go get those for free and tell us how
much you enjoyed it let's get back to
the show and then you guys look like
[ __ ] oh yeah you're Scott you're [ __ ]
done but I say son yeah you get away
with using son like maybe you know
[ __ ] 44 I'm a cute [ __ ] kid I'm
like a black eye you got a Tesla now so
here's my point that's okay Germans were
like Nazis [ __ ] Nazi cuz they never
learn you know like we CK got caught
Greeks okay huh lonely man every sin 1
10 15 20 % we gotta reproduce so
nature's kept the 75% but anything
that's evolved and smart is a little gay
let's be honest nobody goes to a [ __ ]
neighborhood because like all the jocks
are moving there it's like the lesbians
are there buy a [ __ ] house she's a
good point I bet yes Amen or gay people
have higher IQs and strays I'll cross
the board actually because I think it's
a more evolved thing I'd yeah when you
start to get evolved like you honest was
saying you start to have sex with every
day there's an evolving no no I think
it's evolving
I think it's evolve cuz you're there's
more holes what's the point of life well
the point of life is to have a [ __ ]
cute time and to make sure everything
matches is so epicurean here I'll tell
you this I've procreated right have a
beautiful daughter yeah and I've said
this before now you've stopped living
now I've stopped living but I think the
first 50 years of my life I'm straight
I'd like to go the last 50 by the hell
not you really gay would you really go
gay reality is a suggest training I've
never at up at a training my eyeballs
did
not some other kid some other kid those
are brothers yeah
oh look but so never never once no
training I looked up at a training I'll
tell you this yeah I've said before that
I you know romantically I'm physically
attracted to women but emotionally
attracted to guys yeah you can have a
good conversation I want to [ __ ] a girl
for sure yeah I've never I've never done
anything physically gay so I don't know
that I could ever receive a dick or give
a dick in an ass yeah in a guy's ass
mouth mouth or mouth but I I could
certainly I think find myself in
relationship with the guy wanna pee
that's a little holding hands or we're
doing you know like I would let a guy
nibble on my ear law of no problem but I
think once it starts to get to sex it
statements to be a vagina and it needs
to be I've been born a vagina that's not
gay man I gotta be honest with you
that's really just driving straight
you're just describing dudes hanging out
yeah a little bit a we're describing
friendship yeah
well the fingers win in Ridgewood where
I grew up that a lot any it was so I'm
always asking the honesty's this gay
exactly cuz like literally if you did
anything that was like if I would if I
would like let you wear it borrow like
my basketball shorts that's it I know
it's [ __ ] gay my dick was on that
what are you gay or if I was like yo I
got a I got a B+ to like from suckin
[ __ ]
and it's like whoa good grades is gay
cuz that's why when I found you on it
sounds like yo dude you can talk about
history you could talk about your
feelings it's not gay but I came from a
neighborhood where it's like yo if
you're not anyway if you try to kiss me
I was like whoa yeah no no no I put my
head down cuz he thought he was gay he
was like he felt I said it's okay to
like like art and like like history and
then he just assumed he was gay mm-hmm
and he tried to kiss me I was like no
man I was too much smart yeah if it was
smart then that means it's gay but even
in great culture right where there's a
lot of promiscuity amongst men asexual
tastes like a Turkish sultan
okay like I like all levels of woman
okay so it's like I'll take a full woman
and then anything that looks like it's
getting banged out all right if you can
pull it off I'm fooled its credit to you
salute
so you'd you'd have you hooked up with a
[ __ ] no but I absolutely [ __ ] would
but you want straight a blonde one hold
on Freddie Portugal on one second I
don't believe it I absolutely would
you would hook up with a train I don't
care what do I care yeah I don't know if
I do anal I don't like anal when you're
single you are happily man yeah I'm
happily happily merrily you're saying
woman for now for now you would hook up
with a [ __ ] yeah 100%
I'm sorry so so dick still attached just
wearing make I prefer the dick because
notice this about okay so we watched
three clever he watch a documentary on
this story back that's how you get away
with doing Murray so you're like I'm
about it no no no I I'm a trap if I see
someone and I'm attracted to them yeah
right like you're attractive yeah you
eat maybe we root when it's on the ball
I'll be on burger burger like a plastic
piece of you're calling them not real to
me they're real people
no they're real people or sex real
plastic saiga don't them are sexy ass
who who do you like who's your face I
don't know any [ __ ] name but I mean
like if you ever seen her lei Li Jiang
belly just kind of hot yeah it's kind of
hot yeah would you take it down taking
estrogen would you throw at it would you
throat it I don't know if I throw it it
that gets a little weird but you're
asking me hypotheticals guess I'm in the
moment and I'm horned up and like she
looks like a woman I mean you know what
how can you look like one with huge set
of [ __ ] and balls that part looks like a
man but you said you prefer that huh no
I'm saying if I'm hooking up with a
[ __ ] I would prefer that over a kind
of if I knew it was kind of a created
over at perfect [ __ ] right I don't know
no no no they literally it's made that
one's kind of like a not a real [ __ ]
yeah but so this is Bailey Jay what's
the man you guys should just [ __ ]
lying
became a man remember he's like the
jacked guy but it was born a woman buck
something let me ask you questions if
you had the choice the guy who Ben if
you had the choice yeah there's a tons
maybe seal thing that's that's a
transgender the way
that's a choice to hook up with a male
to female trans or a or a female to male
trance
yeah like buck angel his name's bucket
yeah we just won would you hook up but
if you have this is a woman you
understand you know you load on your
butt this idle conversation hi boyfriend
let us indulge yeah this is a great one
oh this is one of my favorite hi but
that it was ever I've never played this
one try it you're saying would you have
to hook up with you mails it or female
to milk us huh the female is locked
everything is flopped a woman the woman
has a penis the man what looks like a
man has a vagina buck angel are you
attracted to this this is this this
young man was born with the air this is
not a woman it looks like that was
[ __ ] Heisenberg now that that was a
woman you can't say neither cuz that
that that's no I get out of it that way
so here's the thing ya salute her what's
tricky doesn't have a vagina he has a
vagina pony girl's got a cop yo no no no
she was born with the vagina vagina and
so what happened
hearts let me just set the parameters
we're keeping original parts everything
else has changed yeah so holy J people
from a time that's going away pretty so
this is of surgery has a full [ __ ] now
here's the thing this is get cracked no
thing there are certain things that I
don't like if a girl or a guy has it
yeah a penis is one of them penis is one
of them but also hair see my rules are
just now strict as yours feet so hair is
a big know if there's a chick there's a
chick who was working at the comedy club
did you notice at helium Portland one of
the girls who was taking over the dudes
who's taking pictures after the show
[ __ ] but has facial and everything I
got a portly egg looking like anyway
doesn't matter [ __ ] that is a really
interesting one because I bet most
people would rather Bailey J then books
what does the guy know they would
everyone's lying why we talked about
this I said I'd rather [ __ ] everybody
just why because I for me for
you know like a guy I'm supportive of it
all it's actually perfect it looks like
a guy but it has a [ __ ] it's like yeah
sorry people some people may prefer that
because they were but either way who
cares yeah we watched the whole
neuroscience documentary we saw if even
us we don't even realize we do this is
subconscious at times men straight
heterosexual straight men will click
through porn where the girl is hot it's
a born woman and the man's penis is
flaccid they'll click through that what
you want to see sexual your brain is
sexually aroused by hard [ __ ] and big
tits so that's why a transgendered woman
is excitable 2 straight men and why they
can jerk off because they have the big
[ __ ] and they have the big tits and
those are the things so so in other
words a hard dick excites a heterosexual
man more than a wet [ __ ] in point yes
gay guys do not like trans women on a
transfer man and also here's the other
thing that they know is that trans porn
is one of the most searched hears
abhorrence try straight people so people
are just lying we did this on this
podcast like lies but and that an
Instagram actually took down a clip but
I was made the argument that [ __ ] porn
is straighter because there's just more
tits it's the same amount of dick and
[ __ ] but two more matically can't argue
with the math but the hard dick is about
you imagining yourself as the person in
the porn yeah and you don't want imagine
yourself soft I think what the
neuroscientist was saying scrambles a
bunch of symbols I forget what are they
say in the hood about it say again what
are they saying in the hood away from me
but they're saying it's scrambling a
bunch of snow back to Germany dog yeah
sure we learn India a very homophobic
place right yeah a little bit yeah a lot
of homosexuality yeah in the Muslim
world it's the same thing like it's very
homo it's a you talk to anyone who's
been there it's like it's a very taboo
thing whatever's taboo is gonna make
yeah you got to admit at least when it
comes to that when it comes to the
homophobia and
stuff like that that's that's a white
people problem in the sense of we're the
only ones that get in trouble for it cuz
rap songs are people in Indiana hey
check it go call everyone homogeneous
and that it was like we love you Eminem
yeah yeah because it's like this is that
we live in actually one of the most
progressive places on the planet
liberals are afraid of right black goes
back to criticize a black person ever
ever ever got to know everybody's behind
him including other black people that is
true but also white people operating
extremes mmm right so we're probably the
most terrifying and hateful but also by
far the most progressive hmm right
there's no other group of people cares
about let's just say what it is knows
are the best like think about like there
is this thing about like
environmentalism and all this got me
Native Americans care about that [ __ ]
but that's baked in they gotta care but
do you really think they give a [ __ ]
about environmental no [ __ ] like modern
Native Americans I don't know modern day
I modern debt maybe back in the day
because they're like living off it
whatever but you were connected to
Americans were also like they were just
Scott they've the [ __ ] horrendous
[ __ ] to their people too especially is
tribalism well some of them didn't some
of them did I mean they used to [ __ ]
scalp their own toe and wild the
Comanches would lie Wow
but it's like all the white man gave you
smallpox yeah we did guy real would you
like to cut out your [ __ ] your rival
tribes organize reason you know history
so you can say
the point you never let me get out let
me get to the job we got it yeah say
whatever I want swear on my daughter
okay I would never lie I voted for Obama
twice and I voted for Hillary but make
no mistake come November
Trump is good for Hillary it is not a
safe thing in this [ __ ] world that
hasn't changed me from the fact that try
Hillary's I wish I could vote right now
yeah you wouldn't vote for my friend
who's gonna die just like Bubbe
he said can we edit that out the Hillary
part that's gonna hurt on numbers well I
vote for him
I don't know Hillary's just I did vote
for her Wow I wasn't enlightened yet but
now it's like now I get the liberal [ __ ]
it you know I don't [ __ ] now I'm
like okay I'm not gonna sit here and
judge people for who they vote I you
know I don't judge people how they vote
or their sexuality we're too judgmental
now you think that's a free country
everyone want to feel about Catholics
huh of a system that is set up for
pedophilia there's no question you if
you were a queen of doors Lord what
would your castle look like great [ __ ]
point and you got me it's so funny it's
so funny what Yanis what you're honest
and I talk because it's like you know we
talk all the time you know or in the
park is wheat all the time and he's
always like the same things like the
Greeks did this the Greeks invented that
they do this and almost like yeah but
nobody cares people don't care about the
Greeks at all it's all about the Irish
in the Italian what have you done from
you know what have you get some right so
we are the al-basri of country here oh I
just talk about the glory days all the
time it's parrot was it's for the French
the same way yeah and Egyptians all the
Ori of you guys are living in the past
your museums dude you're [ __ ] Museum
culture and it's really weird and
Italy's about to be there it's German
interesting thing though that he went
with it because his last name is de
Stefano yeah oh yeah all the bits about
your father don't tell anybody that was
in the Italian version in this version
he pushed them into imeem you're you are
german german kid from ridgewood all
right let's take a break for a second we
gotta pay some bills here we fix cereal
we fixed it we fix cereal not when I say
cereal I'm talking about breakfast
cereal you know that thing that we ate
in the morning that had so much sugar
and carbohydrates that we would go to
school and then the school would say
that we had a TD when we didn't really
have a TD we just had so much sugar or
carbohydrates that we were just
literally methed out at school do you
remember that that's why we couldn't
learn anything okay they cook all the
[ __ ] out of cereal magic spoon it's
a company you might have heard me talk
about before they sent me the four
cereals that they have they're [ __ ]
delicious they're healthy their Kido
their Kido
okay there's no gluten in these things
let me get all the different things they
have they have a the cocoa flavor the
fruity flavor the frosted flavor the
blueberry flavor all right
zero sugar twelve grams of protein only
three net carbs in each serving okay you
know me I'm off the bread I
cereal absolutely dee-licious keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
so men you're not growing no titties out
there low-carb GMO free magic spoon is
where it's at
absolutely delicious I love the fruity
one I love the frosted one and I love
that Coco that blueberry ain't bad
either if you go to magic spoon ma GIC
SPO and.com slash flagrant they're gonna
send you the variety pack with free
shipping you go get that free shipping
go get this cereal if you got kids make
sure they're eating decent stuff okay
that's what's most important make sure
you know it's your kids it's going to
your kid's body if you enjoy a nice bowl
of cereal put some good stuff in your
body it's fantastic it's absolutely
delicious you're my girl still loves
like the sugary cereals and I started
eating my like I'm 35 I can't do this
bro you can't have that much sugar but
it tastes so good it tastes so good so
they found a way to get around that they
say it's perfect
magic spoon calm slash flagrant go get
it now let's get back to the show I
didn't know it was a German neighborhood
till I met you know this is creamer in
the rock was like a bad guy and then I
became like the hero yeah that's your
doing man I don't even got the hair dude
this is amazing I like to just get out
or do it yeah like I tweeted the other
day that I [ __ ] it bombed on Jimmy
Kimmel Oh baby
and I just people like why would you do
that it's like cuz what am I gonna do
[ __ ] it fake like that did a story
awesome everybody who's listening
because again I would have noticed a lot
of times we do on podcast especially
comedians is we act like everybody
listening is in our tiny little bubble
of a [ __ ] world most people don't
even know Jimmy Kimmel has stand-up on
it good call okay so breakdown you go
out to LA right I go to Los Angeles you
all the podcast you're killing it do all
the pockets I mean I'm on oh you're on a
high I'm having good I mean yeah like
I'm swinging yes just right ft honest
here yeah it's left left behind why'd
you leave them behind just literally I
got in the / I was like just take me to
Rogen studio now does he get me they
just got stopped by Israeli security on
the way
a Jew it's American security now Odilon
severe Israeli guys no no no no all Navy
SEALs okay Tim said they were guys
Israeli guys all body we're gonna
[ __ ] work okay so not good you're out
there you go to Jimmy Kimmel to do the
stand-up now most stand-up most
late-night shows you do stand up in
front of the audience that the
late-night show is being recorded yes
not Kimmel not Kimmel and you're at the
end usually of the show like any type of
other late night - Tonight Show Jimmy
Fallon whatever you're at the end of the
show the audience is warm there's been a
whole show and then like hey we're gonna
have some stand-up it's been great that
this is in Las Vegas at Jimmy Kimmel's
comedy clubs right so they will pump the
stand-up into the actual show when it
airs but in the moment you're at Jimmy
Kimmel's comedy club now
it's 300 people packed sold-out show of
course they're free tickets to watch it
- a taping TV taping you do five minutes
you have to do the five minutes that you
already got approved okay so you can't
really deviate the first just - just to
let everybody know the late-night five
minutes is highly scrutinized every
single word every single word and
they're these Booker's do they will
quote unquote help you with your set so
people who've never done stand-up comedy
before in their lives will be like hey
maybe you should try this word yeah
maybe do they do a lot of that editing
is that all that yeah it is your set
yeah you can't say this you can't say
that right you know it's a very
unnatural environment that's why people
don't enjoy it we don't enjoy but
usually I've done other late-night sets
it's in front of a hot audience they are
told to laugh and they know what's
happening this show is at a comedy club
so it's already one strike again sweets
had a big cavernous comedy club Jimmy
Kimmel's comedy club it's a nice enough
room but it's cavernous and big high
ceilings just not good for comedy Kimmo
who's never done stand-up
zoom has his own comedy club maybe add I
don't know if he huh I never knew him to
be us don't know I don't know actually
from the man show and it was really
funny before he did the late-night stick
I got to be with a man show like he was
fun Adam Carolla he's a stand-up yeah
yeah you know Adam Carolla does stand-up
comic in the stand-up he's not like even
a real Adam does it but he's like more
of like a radio guy like that's his like
background backer but he does he Adam as
well yeah you can tell he's doing bits
like I've heard him on radio in a reason
you can tell this guy's working on
material he's got honey balsamic he
operates in bits even you talk to him
person-to-person I could do a bit it's
kind of odd yeah so so this one they
don't have a warm-up comic yeah well
they had a warm-up comic who did like
three minutes right and warm-up comic is
usually like playing games with the
audience hey we're gonna have it TV tape
yes to get the audience exactly warmed
up because at the beginning of a does it
doesn't so what happened was the little
warm-up comic guy went out three minutes
whatever bombed then then his sister who
I had no idea does standing me Kimmel
great actually
she's sweet girl I did a show in Tempe
with her yeah Joakim oh she opened for
me I didn't realize it jimmy kimmel
sister i was like oh she's really nice
and i found out later as jimmy kimmel
sister yeah she goes a tour dick yep
just took a hot one and then and then
and then and then brought me out right
up chrissie right up to the you notice
podcast the hyenas of history so so as
I'm going out I kind of just know that
this is going to be easy it was one of
those when you clap when you go out on
stage you know like they stopped
clapping before I even got to the mic on
a late-night show so I'm like yeah keys
so I come out and I had a thing of mine
I was like maybe she just do crowd work
and just then maybe I should warm them
up and then do the SEPA I was like they
was yes if about five minutes and I said
rude to be honest with you the truth of
the reason why I really didn't do it as
I was taking a red-eye flight to get the
[ __ ] out of Vegas in two hours so like I
kind of don't want to miss my flight say
your travel plans are why you bombed
behave well because I already knew that
the views on Theo Vaughn's podcast and
fighter in the kid were gonna be twice
maybe three times as much as Jimmy
Kimmel and I knew that I had done the
work why went out there
I did the work that benefits me yeah
this is like I don't want a bomb and I
don't want it to be bad but I kind of
don't care I mean I why everybody don't
care also for those who don't know doing
late night sets back in like the 80s
change your life your career Johnny
Carson could change your life now it's
not almost opinion yeah I usually the
worst version of myself right out to an
audience who doesn't really care about
here I dress like I would never dress
telling jokes how I would never tell
them yeah and you delay my attention
realistically done for your like numbers
of ticket sales zero zero zero zero why
did you do not a thing
so you go up you decide not to do a
minute a crowd work to where I must as
you would miss your flight but yeah and
so I go out there yeah what's the first
joke the first joke was um well first of
all yeah I was like I kind of like
played it down I was like I was like
yeah I was like give it up for Jill give
it up for Jill and then it was just like
Shh and then and then nobody clapped and
then I was like and then I was like well
that's the best when you think like and
then I'm about to turn it out and then I
was like I'm on Jeannie I was like Jimmy
Kimmel cute like that zero yeah and then
I was like so I was like do you think
more people need to get punched in the
face
nobody said anything and I was like okay
and then I just and then I did the bit
and it got ok and then I did a bit about
the next bit was about a cousin of mine
having a peanut allergy and that really
ate a dick and then three minutes
actually a great bit thank you as much
as I'm having fun with you bombing with
you taking the bombing jokes instead of
me yeah three minutes three minutes into
my late-night TV set I said you guys
[ __ ] suck I said that Chris Wragge a
curse word you work I'm sure they'll
edit it out right that was like you guys
so then that bombed and then I continued
the set and then I just got off in the
middle of kind of like half a [ __ ]
laugh at what I thought was going to be
the same closer well I actually wound up
doing my closer from my hour set that
I'm gonna do that wasn't approved by
Kimmel just to be like they're not gonna
let me just try something and that
pumped right so I was just like
so then I get off stage and the producer
is like oh man he was like don't war he
was like how it was I was like that
crowd [ __ ] stinks and he was like
don't worry well pump laughs into it I
said you better air that thing as the
bomb that it is love it I said the last
thing I ever want is you to pump laughs
into that I said it's got to be truthful
I said this is why this format [ __ ]
blows yeah I was like because yesterday
I was able to tell the truth about
myself for two hours and it was great so
it is your truth so it's like so it's
like five this five minute [ __ ] that
I just had to do I said I regretted in
doing it he goes the first comic always
say except more stories you ever feel
it's tough one dude I need to listen
that Bodkins just so you guys can go
back and forth one time I was catching a
monkey with her or you know or I [ __ ]
tell you the truth it's either I sell
the ticket or I don't know that's why we
balance each other out so well yes
because I think I come to real right and
he bounces out with just fun it doesn't
matter if it's real or not right because
like I just it's like mine I sometimes
I'm too real and yeah sometimes he's not
real at all so it's like it's a fun BAM
it's honor of the balance yeah all right
so about the by the way I want to say
real quick if Jill hears this IV you're
great I just it was just a situation
where I was like everybody ate a dick
but you were saying Brad Williams from
the adidas toward portlet which [ __ ]
that blows do not go and I'm like
Chrissy what's going on is everything
okay like my god I was concerned
concerned sure and you're like yeah you
know I did bad at Joe Hart I everybody
suck Brad Williams called me said he
[ __ ] killed and I was like you know
what buddy I don't want to hear that you
killed right now what I should have done
his bold you tone it to the audience
[Laughter]
got my slingshot Shelby do not take it
from him yeah yeah I mean it was just I
mean it was literally one of those
things where I hope it goes so bad it's
one of those things first of all I
tweeted it out and it's the most
favorited retweeted tweet I've ever had
Twitter let me know that so now it's
like I actually have a chance if people
may be watching this set
I told case scenario is that you bomb on
one of those things yeah we think if I
crush nobody's gonna care at least now
the BIC oh I'm gonna watch when this guy
comes out yeah I mean it's just it takes
it yeah it's just I mean that's the way
to kill a late night actually this bad
let me watch other clips and then you go
see the clips in the control area yeah
dude that's the beauty right now of
clips and I'm not trying to like tap
into whatever the [ __ ] but when you have
proof that you're funny out there and I
think does it matter as much in a day
you had one thing on the innocent matter
anyway you decided good one who cares no
the fact of the day there was one thing
to decide if you were good or not right
the last average person yeah now you
have a million things right show
somebody if you have this shitty set
doesn't matter they go check out the 911
story they check out these different
lines this guy's a funny dude we have so
much more control of like how we're
perceived out there do you remember when
our friends would have a bad late night
set dude it's like funeral who's the guy
with like a Twitter that did Kimmel ha
Rob Delaney London he's in London doing
TV boring as [ __ ] they love that
expunged like that say again he how did
he get it expunged from the internet
Christopher do you have any idea
yeah you gotta told me there are some
Jew on a set it's gonna be good I can't
wait just now I'm more excited to have a
watch party yeah the only problem that
I'm excited to see it the only problem
that I'm thinking about is maybe it
didn't go that bad as I thought it did
in my head and it's gonna be like oh now
it just looks like a mediocre set but in
my eye fell the others worse
I felt the box if it's mediocre that's
it's it's not as good as a bomb I'm
hoping for a bomb I'm hoping it's a bomb
No
yeah you need to have if you have people
I don't if you have people you need to
have them make sure they don't pump in
laughs they don't do any I told them to
make sure not to because if you see a
comic not getting last he bombed yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I hope that they
leave I hope they just bleep out you
guys [ __ ] suck as opposed to editing
out completely yeah yeah that's it's so
funny that if they tried not there and
you call them and say come on give me
this give me the body for a buck you
know everything is on its head right now
we live in a reality that's kind of on
its head well everything is wild right
now yeah like a bomb on late night is a
success and it really is yeah because it
is so fabricated right and they could
make anything look good that you want to
show them the truth because that error
is over that error it's so transparent
that that era was contrived now because
you have something to compare it to
which is this how do you trying
themselves all about shining through
yeah what are you doing that shines
through
sometimes bombing is more authentic and
authenticity we're gonna do it first
Marina Philadelphia that like it was a
prophetic thing I mean like even you
know I use I use your 9/11 story as an
example for a lot of time for comics
about like like creating a funnel for
yourself on the Internet
yeah it's like you never had a funnel
you had things but nothing really drew
people in no and then once you get a
funnel all the sudden there's one thing
that pulls everybody into your life and
now you have these other things that
they can go digest yeah and that's what
I've always tried to create with myself
on the internet wasn't just like clips
there's a reason why I told you not to
put out the whole special yeah you know
it was if you create the clips they're
just other
opportunities for a funnel you know
Chris D'Elia has a joke about these
drunk girls that he tells me every year
it goes viral again so new groups of
girls are finding this joke and then
there's another part of him doing that
joke I move started in LA 2007 I
remember a joke and it's crazy and it's
like one of these toy stores like one is
first bits and be like that's very funny
the act out is so strong whatever but
hearing that goes viral all the time now
twelve hours it continues to it so it's
like now you have the funnel and you
know you know for me maybe it was the
women and food joke that I had you
remember that yeah that was one like 441
or like the crowd work special but that
was really the thing that opened what
your what you're talking about the fun
who everybody wants a funnel but what
you need more than funnel is other thumb
to go to man Jordan that's where the
podcast is so important are putting out
weekly consumes them a place to go to
check you check out with boom everywhere
you see it instantaneously it's like I
bet right after that story hit you start
selling some tickets hell yeah right it
was almost he was selling tickets before
to from pop-up girls got to eat you sold
out yeah but I wasn't selling his
boyfriend but adding theater shows and
all that that's nine Elijah yeah and
I'll tell you the comedies I did that
story on my Comedy Central our special
and it kind of just came and went
because I had to do it their way you
know the camera angles and ooh can't say
this we don't want to offend you know
it's said I did a drunk at the comedy
saw on 9/11 yes
ain't a [ __ ] with their camera and it
went viral and because it was so wait a
minute you owe your career to brown
people yes yeah thank you soon what
bothers you more in your careers you
think I am I told you I've told you this
[ __ ] bromine literally number one
woman I mean it's chubby Indian women I
[ __ ] love chubby the audience right
you have to I told you I [ __ ] I'm always
with a chubby Indian girl I love Indian
people I [ __ ] love you guys you know
we paid you back absolutely I appreciate
it yeah I love it
point is you had a vote I can't deal
with yeah yeah yeah I don't know I mean
every time an Indian restaurant opens in
Bay Ridge I'm like what are we doing
here nobody wants to [ __ ] just put up
pizzeria or bagel stri me what is this
Viet routes get the [ __ ] outta you're
actually scared to live in a world with
no racism what's that gonna be like what
do you mean well it's like everything's
you guys are doing German and Italian
and I'm not even making a joke I
don't give a [ __ ] about German Italian
but to you guys it's like a big deal as
we become more like I guess homogenized
or whatever we'll still find the German
Italian thing Indians do it yelling give
a [ __ ] when you have no enemy it's like
when you have no enemy
it's a you don't know what to do with
you look at the people who have no enemy
they created that antiva creates an
enemy you're always gonna create in the
end of good we'll find it we'll do it
with eye color always do this yeah I can
hairline so what girls do to each other
cuz cuz race is back now you hear and
you just like are we still doing that
what racism it's kind of like [ __ ]
boring not if you haven't heard some
good old racism what does Cologne and
our source Bravo's trending on Twitter
yesterday was people were calling it the
come flu what are the funniest Corona
nicknames you've heard the flu aronia
Vilas everybody goes through their shoes
almost like yeah I can't go there
because the Oriental owned the Oriental
lung the Oriental one right it's good
someone on that ticket called it Hong
Kong fluey
and I thought fantastic good jokes agree
I'm talking about like actual real
racism kind of like what do you mean
it's like when someone like truly like
killing people cuz I totally hate when
they're trying to give you their mantra
see how we're doing a bit and then you
come in with
see how is happening yelling yeah our
Park is just a constant me say something
to series that him just yelling I'm gay
yeah yeah you got it that's a good
podcast but we also talk about history
yeah we talk about history as well I
yeah I don't know man it's a good point
I [ __ ] everybody yeah what was the see
how you did that man having Hong Kong
fluey cun-cun Colonna yeah I took the
era of fun we're gonna go through it
everybody goes through it it's just what
it is there's a I got well what about
[ __ ] Inc off
[Laughter]
no good more no nothing there's call me
something thank us on yeah well I can't
think of any good racism right now
there's gotta be something good yeah
Slaney sickle cell we're just doing any
different all right let's go we got this
let's do this Coogan car was [ __ ]
good it's good who can call school like
a German anime character yeah yeah oh
that cold what is it
clothes i cold and we can get better all
right well we're starting with the gugak
off it's all gonna go downhill on a roll
no cuz the watch controls the asia what
do we got asian so we're getting too far
away from it Keukenhof was good it's got
to be punny the brainstorm meeting at
Ronny Chang their play on Orient Express
or infamous oriental how about chopstick
is pretty good Hong Kong fluey I like
almost one Kong flu small like smallpox
yeah
alright guys let's take a break for a
second there is a company that we've
been talking to him for a while it was a
product that I had to try before I
okayed it for the podcast I had to have
my expert my PhD give a try as well to
make sure it was legit because it seems
almost too good to be true
but the company's called power dot and
[Applause]
essentially I'll let the doctor here
explain doctor saying what what do you
say about this power to thank you for
having me on the ship course absolutely
and now I'm gonna be honest when you
talk to me about it I very Indian Lee
was like I'm
kepta collector and i legit did research
okay and there's two kinds of technology
there's EMS which is like electro
muscular stimulation or something and
then tens and tens is the one I looked
into first and foremost because that's
about recovery and in any workout you do
you recoveries the most important thing
right one of the reasons I never get any
bigger is because I'm [ __ ] sore after
every workout for like two or three days
this is clinically proven I literally
looked into my insurance plan they
approved ten stimulation for pain
management and recovery really like that
yeah if you're in pain you can use this
kind of technology tense one of the two
technologies to help you not be in pain
it works for muscle recovery right
chronic back pain any of that kind of
stuff this works now these are the dots
you put these on your muscles you attach
that thing and then this is this is the
power control you also have an app that
controls it so you just turn this on it
is it's like the old Electra Matic
magnetic stimulation thing they're like
Bruce Lee used but the difference is
they combine that with this tens
technology and that's what separates it
from okay so basically we work out our
muscles get torn apart in order for our
muscles to build they need to recover
cover what are all HGH those
performance-enhancing drug all those
things are just speeding up recovery
covery aids their recovery it's that's
all they do they just increase cell
growth now some people go get massages
after workouts you see a lot of athletes
a dozen Russell Wilson yeah all these
athletes you always see them on the
massage cher concert massage and it's
literally trying to massage those
muscles back to health this thing the
power dot same thing that's what it does
it stimulates it but even faster because
it's using electricity yes which for
some reason is better than hands always
faster than manual anything electric is
faster than man you great point
Alex Tesla exactly yeah I'm right facts
and a cool thing is when I got injured
when I was in law enforcement yeah when
I went to physical therapy technology
and I had to look into Howard odd it's
called by the way don't look up tens
there's that's a strip club that they
have I think in Queens there's a strip
club in Queens I don't believe so
maybe not twins but sinister starlets
this is strip club you look into it
research it power dot no but keep going
yeah if you look up that technology it's
legit studies say it's legit the
insurance companies they're not covering
anything that doesn't work I mean
they're not
money at health insurance companies
right so it's this is a must be legit
look guys go recover faster we got an
offer for the US customers only
30-day trial plus an additional 20% off
for our listeners okay go to power
dot-com slash flagrant power dot-com
slash flagrant okay
use the code flagrant at checkout twenty
percent off your order
again that's power do t-dot-com
slash flagrant and use the code flagrant
for twenty percent off let's get back to
the show
bubonic plague I think there's something
there something in bubonic plague yeah I
think it could be but it goes back to
the guqin pub but it's go conic play I
think I can I get canceled for cooking
coffee no okay time honey nobody is
cancer in you that's what I was telling
Shane I was like bro if that came out a
few months later your to TV at this
point man oh yeah
you're like under you're like Donnie
Brasco for saying things like that
you're a but you know what though it's
weird because like I keep going on dish
you don't have to worry about this one
no but I keep getting like you know TV
by the cartoon and development now on
Comedy Central they're like you know we
know the podcast it's fine
wow really I say wild [ __ ] I think it
like it's fun if you landed something
then that they don't dig back it's like
some guy like some independent guy I
almost feel like we're past that to
where it's like I know how to tell you
yeah I hope so you know yeah why why
don't more cancellations call me central
um because they told me that I don't
have to do like give up anything or like
you keep doing the podcast keep doing
the internet stuff like we're just it's
really no it's minimal work fee we wrote
we had wrote in the script the script
was wrote written last year something
like where they bought it gave me a full
22 minute pilot so you know I still the
thing is with TV there still is some
money in TV so I still can cash it as
just Comedy Central money that's not
convenient so you just well that's think
it's not a convenience it's all in New
York New York or LA no I just don't
check that and it's a they told me that
most you'll have to do is if we get too
serious the most don't have to do is two
hours two to three hours twice a week
from a sound booth in New York oh no no
but though the work is gonna be great is
just like if it's a passion of yours to
have this show
and you won't have multiple seasons
Comedy Central is not the place to do it
well the thing is though I know with the
money it is interesting because the
money is like even we were talking when
I was on fighter in the kid like yeah
it's like Bryan Callen said it on his
own podcast he was like yeah man he was
like I mean I like doing ABC shows he's
like but it's not even comparable to the
money I get in podcasting in the fans I
get in podcasting yeah he's like I'll
sell a thousand tickets wherever I go
plus it's only fighter in the kid faith
understand it's very very true it's a
wild thing to think about
its economy central shocks me how
[ __ ] [ __ ] they are because like
they have two shows that work on that
network right and they're the most edgy
shows like South Park and Tosh Tosh
right they're the two shows that are
literally decades long decades long but
sexist racist homophobic like they're
literally all the [ __ ] up jokes most
flagrant shows that would exist on that
network work every other show sucks the
Comedy Cellar show gets a point zero
three rating really thirty thousand
people watch it crazy okay now that's
crazy you would think that they would go
edgy like the other two shows that work
on the channel they refuse to go they
picked it up probably aren't there any
more people greenlight it's just a bunch
of dorks hanging up bro they bought Sam
a real special there pumping yeah
they'll figure it out boys all it's on
the I mean why would you give ads to a
TV show anymore right like just give us
the others now right there I went so
Book of Mormon by the way Oh chase about
South Park guys yeah no comedian should
have an ego at all because the South
Park guys are so much better than
everyone else who does comedy right
there they fly above everyone I mean
right that thing is a musical dog I was
dying lat like I was great barreled over
number one eye contact for 22 years ago
I watched Book of Mormon right after
watching Book of Mormon or while I'm
watching it I go there's nothing I say
that should get me canceled ever yeah
they have a baby rape joke yes that is
recurring and called back to in that it
gets an applause break gets it by all
Jewish women yeah that's the only people
who watch Broadway right or musicals
yeah
Hansol old people don't cancel that's a
thing I guess you're right maybe if
young people actually saw it but the
young people are so infatuated with
southpark Muse a smart show sitter
whatever it doesn't matter the point is
if you're not willing to cancel that
you're not willing to cancel that's good
coffee
that's brings I've forgot to mention
this the guy who is dying who I went to
go see right before this 65 year old ooh
should we call him is dead we could I
don't know he might be dead that's why I
think yeah yeah he so he was saying he
goes what I've noticed about people
laying on my death bed is how much of
this world and specifically his country
is all talk he was on some of our
friends that we started with like I
mentioned some names I want to front and
shout him out is that all they do is
write on Facebook about how much they
love me and about how much you know this
and then he said they live in New York
and not one of them has come see me he's
like you didn't write a single thing and
he said and I bet you people would say
if they you know he said they could say
because he was like you know out of all
of us he's like you know your career you
have the one that has a career he's like
they may say oh wow Chris doesn't give a
[ __ ] about you he didn't donate to your
GoFundMe or whatever and he's like you
came and physically saw me yeah he said
and that's what you are cut he like God
enough strength to like get this because
he could barely hear but he was like oh
this whole country is because his son
was there his son is 25 years old he was
like oh I hope when I go to his son he
was like I hope you don't talk I hope
you do and I was like wow because it was
like I feel like all your generation is
talking nobody's doing anything that's
the down that's the dark side I hope you
don't talk I hope that's exactly what he
said to me in a [ __ ] gave me the
chills that's the dark side to the
internet because everyone surprised
Yanis is talking about the dark side
because the dark side the Internet
everyone's pretending to care and they
they don't they don't care everyone's
lying it's like nothing's real and it's
like so when you say something real it
just seems yeah it seems [ __ ] like
this beauty of it for us and say what
the [ __ ] you want who cares
well the story here these people it's a
story about my dad that is true like
it's not fabricated this is just it's
not even funny when Hurricane sandy
happened and the Santa Island got
destroyed my dad lived inland and on the
coast was all like the bungalows it was
like mostly like Hispanic families that
got their [ __ ] [ __ ]
rocked my dad would rent a u-haul truck
or a van every day and go hell
them load their stuff in and out take
the kids to school he had one family
live with him for like a week but my dad
is my dad old-school guy from the Bronx
when they would load this when they were
staying at the house like the guys the
father's name was Jose he would call him
Juan he would tell the kids I'd get on
steal my silverware all like little
jokes he's like you play baseball how do
you play baseball like all just things
were like a woke warrior would be like
you cannot do that like Shaun King would
be like do not yeah you're not doing
[ __ ] you're yelling a lot but my dad was
like I'm physically taking these people
in you know he's like granted like every
time they came to the house he's like
let me see passports and whatever but he
was like still he's like taking them in
I mean I think they weren't there he's
kept him in the garage to go home in the
living room we live in this weird time
where they don't value you built an
extra room to buy just a space here
there he said you can sleep here but
I'll give you a [ __ ] donkey to get
school ya interpersonal relationships
pay nothing now no it's it's an all-time
low like it used to be back in the day
right it was I know that person right he
said something wild one time but I know
him sure I've got a good guy there's
context he probably didn't mean that
now it's you say something one time that
defines you as an individual no matter
what you did with the rest of your life
all right you know I mean like Schindler
was probably said some [ __ ] up things
at the beginning of the movie didn't
give a [ __ ] about any of it he did it so
imagine we just judge Schindler yeah by
the beginning of the movie like [ __ ]
babe Gandhi had 12 year old girlfriends
and wives that's true he didn't have
twelve-year-old wives
no he had but he did cheated right he
had some girls right and Maher Luther
King used to beat the [ __ ] out of his
wife he cheated cheated
what he just said is a hundred times
harder than anything I've said but the
kid has charm he throws it in here
[ __ ] Wiggles I say something you guys
are going whoa whoa what you wouldn't
Yanis you're killing the room he's gone
Martin Luther Krank killed his wife who
[ __ ] his fists and you guys we're
just going well just go and that's what
he did no you're gonna get cleaned safe
killed his wife with his fists
Yanis just let me say it no no Brad my
point is is that everybody's got
something bad about them I mean you
could do such a nice perfect like a
Hitler is that such an atrocity I don't
give a [ __ ] what he did it's like what
you what he did he's out but normal
people this is like I'll find one thing
bad or good about everybody forgets that
they have grandparents when they're on
Twitter right if you just ask yourself
if your grandfather or grandmother has
said anything worse than the person
you're cancelling before you cancel them
you will know the answer very simply yes
my grandma or grandpa said some wild
[ __ ] [ __ ] I still love them they're
still good people I'm not gonna cancel
them simple as that
yeah yeah you know it's just it's a
weird time where like you just can't
know somebody it kind of sucks you know
what it is you know what I think I'll
again really sucks being a father you
know it works when you get something no
they can't cancel you if you're not
trying to get something well if you're
on this world yeah but I think like
being a dad like because you always
think like what am I going to teach my
child how do I set examples for my child
and it's like the world gets smaller
when you become a parent and I think a
lot of people they don't have kids or
like they have a lot of time on their
hands yeah where they're like look like
when how old is your mom when she had
you 35 well she was older okay so my mom
was young 21 but she didn't have time to
be like I'm mad at everything because
she was like I got this [ __ ] child to
raise it's like when you become a parent
you're like yo honestly that sucks that
that happened to you the more I tell my
kid when my daughter asked me stuff when
we have real conversations I'm like
anybody whatever matter what they look
like what religion era you treat them
with kindness and respect that's all you
do so I feel like if I'm doing that and
we make it small like that it's like
yeah I know there's atrocities happening
in [ __ ] Syria and I'm sorry didn't
we'd about it today
Nannette but I [ __ ] teaching my child
that any
who comes in contact with her should you
know you treat them with kindness and
respect unless they're Asian not wearing
a mask
anybody else you try to find this in
respect yeah and then so I'm like so
what am I doing wrong then so you can
you could say I said that I said that
but if I'm telling my kid to do and I'm
making her life smaller what's the
problem then but but but if I said that
to some somebody who wants to visual
deck well no that's gonna solve the
problem so [ __ ] you
here's why you suck click click click
Blagh Blagh Blagh money money money so
it's like it's all [ __ ]
anybody who's loud with stuff like that
that's not a comedian that's and I'm
like I don't trust you at all you're
going off about like this you know
[ __ ] on whatever race you are being
like this is the problem it's like shut
up why do you want the attention again
guy yeah why do you want me to care
about who you are inside of the Internet
is the extremes flourishing both sigh
you can't forget the other side too it's
like those Patriot Prayer people like
they don't see they're just as more the
same person no different neighborhood
still get messages about like people
don't like my politics trying to like
cut me down from the right wing because
I lean left it's like they're the same
[ __ ] person except they carry ak-47
the other ones carry milkshakes it's the
same thing [ __ ] you just like there's
something wrong with you my father has
an eighth grade education literally
eighth grade [ __ ] street education
when Twitter came out whatever 2008-2009
when I first started comedy that's when
I think I think was 2009 he was like you
see his Twitter [ __ ] and I was like
yeah he goes this is gonna be the
biggest problem ever for our country and
I was like why he goes because not
everyone's supposed to be talking hmm
not everyone's supposed to have a voice
you have to be an you're not entitled to
an opinion yeah he said you gotta earn a
public of yet he was like I'm not
supposed to hear from everybody now all
these idiots are gonna start talking
we're gonna have problems and no Brice
tuning in to like a well-reasoned tweet
or personnel [ __ ] is boring
no no question yeah what's weird about
Germany oh yeah about German yeah what
you got tonight I never got to that
point yeah let's finish on that go it's
this is what's fascinating me about
Germans is like like louis c.k he
apologized but he apologized cuz he got
caught right like he didn't like he
didn't like evolved before that and be
like hey you know pretty you know I
shouldn't like it when I tell you
something hilarious yeah it'd be funny
finish this episode and I never get to
do that I know this is really hilarious
yet if you go to the cellar and you go
to the stairs that we walk down to
perform right and there's head shot
pictures of all of us right the headshot
picture of Louie that's on the stairs I
know he's another one that's probably
down but on the stairs it's actually
close to mine is of him in a hotel room
sitting on the bed kind of like weirdly
looking at the tourists right dude it is
so [ __ ] hysterical next time you go
to the cellar just take a pic it's so
funny anybody going germs yeah he thanks
for listening everybody guys check out
history Hyogo so you think the Germans
are not remorseful
no it's they're not remorse it's like
they didn't like you know when you get
caught and you just that's why you're
like hey let's just pretend like you
just just stops he did say it wasn't
like they evolved past and their way wow
that was really wrong what we did yeah
it was kind of like everyone just kind
of went quiet like who all of Ridgewood
was like you know they hit all their
Nazi [ __ ] they like put it away yeah
like they weren't like you know what
that that whole thing was just erroneous
thinking we were wrong they were going
like we got caught yeah but like they
still want to do it you think like Louie
Louie doesn't not want to jerk off in
front of girls in Nice powder yeah I
mean it's like he got caught I feel like
the only reason he's back on stage is to
get big enough that everybody knows and
he can just do it I mean what he did is
innocuous in the grand scheme probably
takes away some of the pleasure it's
just like what's in the realm of like
what's socially acceptable sexually
because it's like jerking off he's six
feet away jerking off more like you
can't do that but I'll let you come on
my face yeah I just don't it's like I'll
take one off the island but if you're
jerking off over there that's
inappropriate
it's like lady I just [ __ ] let you're
corny but it was very consensual you
know talk essential right think there's
a there's a little bit I don't know a
person who's a little bit of like oh
sorry
of it like not the girl doesn't want it
a little bit that's kind of like don't
don't got it on him now I don't think
that's fair because I was at I was at I
was at jfl and I'm not gonna say which
female kind but I had a couple female
comics tell me that they were there in
Aspen when it happened
that's one incident though the other
incident where he was jerking off on the
phone let me just say I don't know it
let me say that's not cool no what do
you mean that's not cool you know me
girls have been fingering themselves on
the phone with me and then they just
start going hey want to know what I'm
doing right now don't but that's the
same [ __ ] different no no it's not
different why is it different it's kind
of like if you hook up if you're a 16
year old kid you hook up with a female
teacher it's a geyser creepier than
girls would you leave your kid with a
guy babysitter or a girl baby I would
never have a guy babysitter but nobody
ever would of course because it's
different actually I had one when I was
a kid I'm and I like really to my
parents as an adult about I was like why
you say we're called him from Scotland
and we left our family I was a [ __ ]
money but uh but yeah but I there was a
female colleague told me she was there
and they asked me and the other girls
were telling her that that weekend in
Aspen at the Comedy Festival they were
all laughing about it it was not this
tragedy where they were like victims
they were laughing amongst the girls
together do you oh my god do you know
what happened blah blah blah blah I mean
I heard other things where like they
were like taking pictures and it was
funny and she's like it was a complete
goof and then it turned into this
tragedy after the fact so I I think in
the grand scheme it's not a big deal I
know you saw Pete Davidson special and
that you feel sorry yeah I'm just going
on that side now yeah I know you rock no
I and I think I think no I don't I he
peeped through Louie under the bus for
some news number one don't give a [ __ ]
atomic maybe 50 year-old man cover to
work I don't want to [ __ ] up weed all
over the place as I'm about to do all
this uh what about to have a [ __ ]
what does a comment give a monologue
monologue get a model alone herself
maybe one of the biggest moments in his
[ __ ] career and you're coming in and
there's weed all over the place
or even I don't that's funny going to
draw the line like that was great I mean
he's not it's like he went out of his
way to snitch on him and nobody likes
they think the joke took a little too
long buddy buddy doesn't like snitches
it's a louis c.k
snitching it's gotta be Louie all I'm
saying is if you're a 50 year old man or
Wow / the [ __ ] of Louis I can understand
if you don't want kids smoking weed when
you come to [ __ ] work right yeah that
completely makes sense
ya know do you tell about that I don't
know do you tell Lauren do you tell he
told Lauren I'm the type of guy where I
go directly to the perfect guy that's
what I do but not everybody's gonna do
that most comics are [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's be honest yeah well how often have
you seen comics clear the morning Louis
doesn't even like sex with the person he
would rather do that maybe maybe that's
what it was but I still some Senate [ __ ]
I'm with Pete on that for sure we don't
even know if it's a true story because
even if Louie came out was like it's not
sure we won't be like shut the [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] pervert yeah it's true is it
nothing's [ __ ] George and take your
dick out you know it's interesting how
the world has changed cuz he wasn't
saying this to me but I heard him say
this and I'm sure he's fine if I say
this because it's a positive thing yeah
he was I heard him say when when this
whole [ __ ] went down he would be sitting
on the train and people would [ __ ]
say awful things to him like accusing
him you're a rapist accusing him of [ __ ]
that's like whoa whoa that's [ __ ] not
even remotely true yeah but I didn't
being accused of that but people are so
crazy
he said nothing's changed all I've done
was gone away and world the world has
continued he said and now people come up
to me ninety five percent people come up
on the train or in public and say I'm
sorry that happened to you or welcome
back happy to see you again he said it
may be the same people so it's just like
this mob mentality one way or another I
have the mob as idiotic you know fast
food we're at the Patrice O'Neal benefit
he did a popin he had a standing ovation
when he walked on I believe you know
when he was Shawn what he did in the
grand scheme is it's not even a crime
it's not well it's not that bad it's not
a crime but let me ask you this let me
even pose this this is just this is just
a question yeah we have a justice system
in this country right we believe in we
pay tax and I know it's unfair to
certain groups I don't know who those
groups are no kidding I know
fair I know what it's unfair and I
understand all that let's take a guy
like Bill Cosby right
what he did was heinous he was in our
system he was put through the service of
the law and all that he does his full
ten years whatever it is ten years full
I believe he should be allowed to come
back and start doing stand-up because
what prison is as you pay your debt to
society you've done that now you are
welcome back in even though whatever if
you if we thought it was so heinous we
never want to see you again you put you
in jail for life we put you in jail for
ten years the victim
it sucks what happened it's robbed about
you paid your debt now you come back you
are allowed to come back I thought about
Michael Vince when his time I feel
didn't want him in the league no he did
his time that's the whole point of the
[ __ ] prison sentence is now I can
return right if you felt like an
especially if you felt like I can be
paroled or I can be let out whatever
then you've decided I'm rehabilitated
appoint of even letting me out of prison
then most you know soap that's what I
just said no it's not because you guys
helped almost the woke people know no I
know but you don't tell them is you got
to be like your issue is not necessarily
with Cosby or Michael Vick here your
issues with the justice system so you
need a lobby the justice system to make
the punishment for killing dogs or
fighting dogs more the punishment for
raise well I think I don't think there's
any of us in here that wouldn't agree
that you could punish rate by the
highest yep thing in the law you'd kill
him I don't give a [ __ ] life sure really
but if the punishment for the crime is
10 years or whatever it is and they do
that you have to let them back you have
to go to their show no absolutely not
you have to go to go you don't have to
do anything but they shouldn't be
blackballed anymore and that's my father
Louis and that's what we get into this
weird thing where he was a trial by
Twitter cuz he didn't actually commit a
crime oh they hadn't pressed charges
ever they depress our charge and so why
was he flat why was he why was he
outlawed ever why was he out whatever
it's it's a mob mentality you know what
I mean he didn't do anything that our
governing system says that he should be
tired suicide believe is about Louis and
Aziz and Aziz did it more I think Aziz
was like woke Bay that's what they
called him he's the old guy Louie
there was a pious naseeb out Louie that
was like oh I'm a great father I'm this
great guy always on the right side of
everything morally and I think when you
see that guy [ __ ] up you're like oh
well
you extra and that's why those guys fell
the hardest sure if you found out I said
if Schultz got accused of the same thing
as these everybody be like yeah of
course really good Andrews house yeah
that's what it is yeah yeah yeah he
would just go long live the fragrance
yeah if you say some racist [ __ ]
everybody can be like of course Chris
whole-brain
I say wild [ __ ] if you mean yes people
of that truth you know many times like
people I'll say something [ __ ] nuts
like some Asian person will say hey GU
Qing COFF was funny to me yeah the only
time I've ever gone somebody the only
time in my whole career that I've ever
gotten somebody angry at me has been a
white woman for course you white women
have gotten angry about things that I've
said when I did that show the ultimate
Beastmaster was only white women or
white men there goes Fung Wong into the
duck sauce song it to the daughters oh
yeah because the Asians are like this is
ten out of ten you know so it's always
white women trying to [ __ ] white
knight it and it's like you're you're
the most racist as we said in the
beginning yeah so I know I'm aware of
that so now I'm just very much like shut
up but that's why I think having a child
is like I'm not trying to sit there and
think about ways to tweet at somebody I
hate cuz I'm like I have to [ __ ]
watch wreck-it Ralph for the third time
and make sure my point doesn't stick our
hand in the nutribullet a great great
movie Sarah Silverman know what else we
didn't finish is what would you guys do
bak angel we conveniently didn't answer
that question yeah I think that for the
next one yeah we'll get back there yeah
guys thank you so much for coming on
make sure you check out Yanis is special
it's on YouTube right now he finally fix
a thumbnail and it looks way better it's
actual arias thing that's gonna do it
well I think it helps because now people
at least know what they're clicking on
true it's all about the advertisement
right if you're advertising a movie but
it doesn't look like a movie then people
are gonna go see it alright I gave it a
try that's the thing I realized about
you you will [ __ ] do the work yeah
you will do it any amount of work I mean
you will not put any time whatsoever
into what works and what doesn't
yeah your your whole days like I will
throw [ __ ] against the wall and if it
sticks I'll [ __ ] Rome etcetera
yeah but what I think is valuable is
going alright what's sticky and then
throw that yeah yeah against the wall
yeah do you own say yeah but it's hard
to know yeah I mean it's hard to know
what sticky and until you [ __ ] up then
you [ __ ] up you're like oh that doesn't
work on me try that yeah but you can you
can you can sit down you can think about
things you can create theorems you know
your people are good at that and you can
figure out how to use those to make it
work every single time be like
Pythagoras bro yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway I love you
make sure you checkout history hyenas
guys go give it a listen great podcast
Chrissy d go check Chrissy on Kimmel and
mom city it's gonna be good it's gonna
be really good love you guys man love
you bad case one of people I know that
we didn't get to any hot topics today
flagrant thoughts etc but we had the
hyenas boys on and you know the
flagrancy is palpable palatable palpable
palpable palpable well it's whatever it
is patreon we won't come through with it
very excited got a lot of things that we
need to discuss we got to talk about
that Izzy fight you know man dude we got
to talk of matter of fact we should give
is he a call we got to give Izzy a call
let's see if he's around he's available
if he's still in the states but yeah we
got to talk about that fight we got a
lot of other interesting thing to talk
about so we will see you guys Friday for
patreon we love y'all we hope y'all
enjoyed the episode make sure you keep
it tight peace
[Applause]
[Music]